welcome to my commentary of game of the
day from the penultimate round of this
great competition and is getting near
the end where they have the final
championships the nerves are getting
there and I'm covering a fantastic game
between Sergei carjacking karyakin and
his up-and-coming the hot property at
the moment in the chess world adi Raisa
firoozeh and Ally Razer is very talented
I mean I think anyone in the chess world
knows they see defeated Magnus in an
online match which is pretty much
unheard of amazing a blitz and rapid
player maybe not quite not to be world
champion yet but keep a close eye on the
kid and this was an extremely exciting
game Sergei hasn't played chess for a
while having a kid he's had a little
break but he comes back to the board
with the carrick on e4 c6 well I have to
say this is Sergey but it's actually
Ally Razer replaced c6 my friend quaint
Jones of England's one of the top
English players told me that if black
wants to play for a win against Eve or
at top level then the CARICOM is now the
most dynamic way to play that obviously
if black wants to save the game you can
play e5 but the carrot Khan is very good
way to unbalance the position we now
have the advanced variation which is the
trend white pushes on in center the
bishop pokes its head out to f5 and now
white plays the short variation which is
Knight f3 and Bishop e2 called the short
variation because it normally leads to
very short games and now Ali razor plays
Knight to e7 now one thing I've always
found with the CARICOM being a French
defence player is that if black can get
into the middle game without any
problems then he generally is doing well
and has a better French defense because
the bishop here is very well positioned
rather than it being on c8 where it's
trapped in this cage
if you can imagine that bishop in the
French defense if you know that opening
being back there it's in this prison of
pawns and with your bishops you don't
want them get stuck in a prison because
it's very hard to get them out to make
them escape and see the light of the day
but with the bishop here it's outside
the prison so it's a much better piece
but I did say if black survives and one
of the problems of the carrot con is
that castling takes quite a lot of time
to do so we had now some developments
and now very logical move black needs to
try and tack this central pawn structure
c5 and now a very NIMS Oh approach
from Sergei rather than trying to
maintain his pawn structure
he immediately captures and c5 and I say
nimza nimzowitsch kind of strategy is a
famous book by nimzowitsch called my
system where he bangs on about the
advantages of having a pawn on e5 and
over defending that pawn with your
pieces basically saying that that pawn
is the winning pawn
he's very optimistic about this pawn but
it is a very occurring and interesting
theme we've even seen this in a previous
video that I've done game of the day
that porn leading to a devastating
attack an eraser now gets his pieces out
he needs to move that night to meet the
bishop now a very interesting move
bishop view for one thing that really
impresses me about Ali razors play and
this game in particular is not just his
tactical ability but is very good
understanding you can just tell he
understands the structure much better
than many mature grandmasters around I
mean I understand this kind of structure
but he basically knows that if he swaps
off his pieces and gets to some middle
game where he's safe he's probably even
got a preferable pawn structure a lot of
players would say cos this over extended
pawn can become weak and black has a
very solid central structure and play
later on down the C file so he's happy
to exchange off and he shows that
maturity
throughout this game the positional
maturity white castles Knight d7 and now
Knights we won interesting moving moved
by Sergey and the point is after the
capture black wins back his pawn and our
Serge's idea is Knight D free attacking
the bishop the bishop retreats and queen
g4 now if I was in white shoes here
Sergei shoes I would be feeling very
confident I'd be like yeah I like this
and this is a very standard ploy to use
when you have this pawn on e5 this
frontal pawn which we talked about
because you're cramping blacks position
and by attacking his King site you're
trying to create either a good attack or
pressure against that side of the board
by forcing black to make a concession
for example if black moves the pawns to
this square he weakens his dart square
so you could even float the bishop nice
and elegantly I'd say just float it in
well we don't actually float pieces
anymore all we do is click we don't have
a chance to move pieces into h6 black
our castle and again Adi raises just
plays King f8 and I've played this kind
of idea of many French defense positions
and I've maybe always got crushed I hate
playing this move I would not be feeling
comfortable with the black pieces here
but again that's where that maturity
evolve you know further in his age comes
in and he raised it realizes that now
white doesn't have a light square Bishop
White's attacking chances are not great
here in actual facts maybe white would
not like to be castled here so you'd go
h4 and swing the rook around to even f3
get another piece into the attack and we
can see throughout the game that really
only White's attack has a big influence
on what happens next so the Queen moves
again and now the King gets a little bit
safer white develops black starts his
counter play against c2 and now rook on
a d1 now I'm really not sure about this
move this is one of those moves you play
automatically you line it up against the
Queen and you think well maybe I can get
the rook around to the Kings side later
but to me it doesn't really have a great
deal of sense and it seems to me that
Sergei starts drifting here and as soon
as you start drifting without a plan it
can go horribly wrong it's better to
have a bad plan than no plan it really
is because you learn from a bad plan and
this is something Spassky x world
champion used to say I mean a move that
I would probably play here for better or
worse as white would be f4 now
definitely black is okay with some night
before starting great counter play or
even the move d4 here but white has to
try and do something proactive I mean
maybe this level is different but up to
super grandmaster strength you've really
got to play of a purpose and the least
this move creates a rook swinging idea
getting wobbled piecing to the attack
try to use all your pieces they've got
to work together work out where they can
be best placed or the upper idea is to
play f5 and just try to open up another
line of attack towards blacks king after
rook on a d1 black now plays Queen a5
and this is a great move it attacks the
pawn and after the poor moose Queen a4
attacking another pawn that pawn moves
and black has got his Queen to a very
active square a little bit of pressure
on the Queen side but can also come over
to the Kings side to give the King a bit
of protection if need be and now we see
a great move a5 if you saw my commentary
on game of the day yesterday this was
you yang Yi versus Duda you might
recognize this plan it's the same theme
to get better at chess you have to
recognize patterns and then put them
into motion and this plan is called the
minority attack black is going to use
his minority upon's to two pawns against
White's majority in order actually to
create some weaknesses over there and
the main plan is b5 be for starting
great play on the Queen side and this
minority attack is very effective in
many positions and it's a standard
approach
white decides to swap off pieces but
black I think is very happy to allow
exchanges because any more attacking
pieces against the black King are
swapped off I mean the thing I find
quite amazing is black plays with this
rook down but it doesn't matter because
white is not doing anything proactive at
the moment he's not finding any way to
prove that's a bad piece H free again
I'm not sure how that helps the knight
comes to a better Square and now very
good move rook C for black improving all
of his pieces and now this rook can even
swing over to the King site it could be
White's King who which becomes the
target so G free stopping the swing and
our queen c6 centralizing the Queen a
bit better and after the Queen moves a
nice move h5 this is trying to stop
white playing a moves such as g4 gaining
a bit of space on the King side g6
consolidating that pawn and now the
minority attacked b5 and I love the way
that you know this play on both wings is
coming into coming into effect by the
young player playing is much more
experienced opponent white still can't
find a plan he plays Knight d3 and now
g5 you give a young man a chance to
attack anybody tack and Ally razor loves
a bit of attacking Queen g2 are now
amateur move and very clever move King
f8 black kind of realizes here that he's
gonna try to break on the Kings side
probably and his King on g8 is not so
well positioned he actually wants it now
in the center where it's very solid
potentially that would give the G farm
some angle as well King to h2 King e7
and now I just wouldn't be able to play
this move I'm sorry I'm sorry - Sergei
he's having a bad a bad day everyone has
a bad day I have them every day well not
every just 99 no anomaly child king he
now plays sit back Queen h1
I mean it's a really bad position
because white doesn't have any porn
breaks he doesn't have any active plans
and again like I said before if you
don't have a plan when you're playing
chess you would just lose normally on
the other hand black has all these porn
breaks it's great to have porn breaks be
for d4g for h4 and white just has to sit
here and basically wait like a you know
come on just hit me in the face will ya
and you know what I only raised the
decides to hit him in the face he plays
rook the eights
not on a rush at the moment rookie for
very clever now the Queen has a way in
it sneaks its way in there's no point
going for a porn break until you've got
the best position you can get you know
you want all your pieces supporting one
of those moves King g1 rook g8 yeah yeah
it's lining up their Queen h1 and now
rook g6 why not improve that one
it's defended here that helps a little
bit Queen g2 and here it comes Knight to
h4 put that in your pipe and smoke it
boy and this is again why the rook is
much better on g6 than g8 because if we
take that knight black simply recaptures
and you can see the rook is now defended
winning the Queen really nice tactics so
white plays Queen h1 and now g4 he does
not mess around and it's really not been
a pleasant time for Sergei he rarely
loses with with White's I mean I don't
think Magnus Carlsen beats him in the
World Championship match did he in the
main game so already Ali Raisins improve
there but I think Sergei is a little bit
rusty having like I said a kid recently
now black had to calculate pawn takes
Knights I mean this position is getting
really bad with a knight coming in here
but there was maybe a clever of defense
which might have even kept Sergei in the
game even in bad positions you've got to
look for all resources and the move be
free here
would have actually given whites and
possibilities the whole point of this is
the Foresters queen away from its most
active square and whatever porn now
black takes we now take the night and
off the king h2 we can actually just
about survive this position because this
queen can not come over to h4 this is
still incredibly dangerous for white but
white is just about hanging on after
Queen f3 and you know this is some
chances to survive if we compare this to
the game and you got to look out for
these hidden resources Sergey goes down
really without a fight he takes on h4
and now after check if we tried the same
line with king h2 which it did not play
rook g2 does Khan can't lose the Queen
and now rook h4 works because this Queen
now has that way to slide sideways and
it can do that and force checkmate with
chick and now rook takes h1 mates and
you can see that little difference that
subtle move the game ended King f1 and
our very nice move I do love a Harry
even if it started off as a Gary h2 the
deadly threat is rook g1 supported by
the pawn white can't do anything about
this if he takes the pawn rook takes h4
is a very pretty position the White
Queen is trapped it is lost it can't go
anywhere and because of blacks active
pieces and whites passive pieces there's
certainly no way to try and defend this
position very impressive play by Ali
razor he he went for the win with the
CARICOM he knew the structure he played
an idea which to me this King g8 move
seemed very risky but he really
understood it and this counts a play
that he started with Queen a5 on the
Queen side was simply brilliant remember
to Like and subscribe if you haven't
done that already
why not and I don't know how good this
this guy's gonna get howdy razor but
he's gonna get good as but he's already
good will he be well champion please
discuss
like Cheers until next time